Google Apps Script is a
cloud-based development
platform for creating
web applications.
With just a browser, you
can build scalable web
applications that integrate
easily with Google products.
Apps Script uses a familiar
JavaScript format.
So you can take what you know
about web development and what
you know about Google products
and create something new
really quick.
Google APIs and user interface
tools are built right into
Apps Script as services.
And the script editor gives
you fast access to all the
services with code completion.
Accustomed to editing HTML?
There's an HTML service
you can use to make
templates and layouts.
And with the same library of
services, you can save data in
Google Spreadsheets, connect to
external databases, or use
the new ScriptDb to create a
JavaScript object store.
When you're ready to share your
web application, publish
it as its own service
with versioning
and shareable libraries.
Apps Script even has quick
publishing to the Chrome Web
Store, where anyone can find,
install, and use your web
application.
To create a new script project
of your own, open Google
Drive, and click Create,
More, Script.
Or just go to script.google.com
to start
your first project today.